naturally I'm plumb doesn't telegram
come back
natural nice like a visible nasty with
marital my my name is Jerry Tom but I've
been telling you
accountants of equity on Tripoli given a
pedigree to mean an especial a penalty
putting the work that I'm doing are the
moving furniture to heaven so let's
expand on shooting for the moon and and
landing on the clouds were shooting for
the clouds are landing on the roof
shoots of the [ __ ] moon because the
stars are better than it did shot this
high because the shooting the clouds you
can end up on the wheel she comes Jordan
to running running for our workout
anyway so anyway what I meant in there
was the fact that matter is that
people's goals are big enough like I
think that people make way too many
short-term goals and they're thinking of
one in three year macros and so for me
one of the great things about trying to
buy the New York Jets is it stretching
my thinking a lot of my behavior is 5 7
12 15 years old long and so I think that
when your goal is to to you know own a
BMW or if your goal is to get a Rolex
watch your behavior becomes more
short-term so one of the things I try to
teach my managers my entrepreneurs my
audience is level up your thinking try
to leave a legacy all the sudden you
become a better person try to buy the
New York Jets all the time you become a
more successful business person stretch
your goal making a promise after this
episode stretch your goals one of the
things to expand on in this weekly recap
is why did I buy pure Loudon so a lot of
pure wild meetings this week obviously
vaynermedia is an agency right a team
we buy ads on websites and other
platforms are creative anything we make
pictures of videos they see on those
platforms but part of my plan always
along with the intermedia was to create
and/or
buy a media company Sports Illustrated
ESPN Kannan s occurs People magazine
but what does that look like at
individual age the age of Vice the age
of refinery29 reached the age of
barstool and so look for about a year
wanted to create a holding company
Vayner X that the vaynermedia stuff
would sit over here and the gallery is
what I call the media world pure
well-being first acquisition in that
world pure welcome media was winning in
that upper millenials low Gen X female
demo which makes the buying decisions of
most products in our homes today that
was a very attractive place Mary Tate
the editor that voices her team
incredible ride Harwood front off the
field watching from afar never even
consider pol because Ryan was a friend
off the field and then stumbled into it
about a few months ago 15 months ago as
a conversation got to the right price on
both engines and made the move and now
the goal is really to create was a great
female media brands of all time around
Pier well so I'm excited about it so
just to round out the repertoire we kind
of have a you know you have a an army
cell of fat man self as different things
and so pure well and media companies
that I'll be looking to get more of a
pure oil is really a huge scale when a
top five seven players in that female
limo but was really built around the
creative story not traffic arbitrage
from Facebook or interim things that
nature plus felt like there's a lot of
what I was learning on Instagram and
Facebook
they applied Sakura so one plus one
equals three scenario and just
regression progression of the journey of
the master plan it was the right time
being or media that scale had to build
out the media property or of this
journey hey Gary I'm having a question
you are building a personal brand next
to your companies and I would like to
know whether everybody should have a
personal brand so businesses come and go
the person stays longer usually let's
say 80 years so it might be a very good
idea to have a personal brand so let us
know please thank you and greetings from
Germany cute house
listen I wrote a book in 2000 I called
crush it about building personal brand
I'm writing a book right now these are
titles crushing it or crushed it that's
my fact it's a good opportunity leave in
the comments what do you think should I
call crushing it or should I call it
crushed it it's a story about the people
that read crush and are winning and an
updated version of how to build a
personal brand in today's environment to
health as far as building a personal
brand alongside your business I'm doing
it I'm a fan of it but I also think I
have the personality the skills the the
stomach adapt its appetite for all the
people that want to troll and things of
that nature I think it's a very personal
thing I think it's like raising a family
it's like a it's like a relationship I
don't want to fly in here and tell you
everybody should everybody who's capable
and wants to should jump into the pool
if you're debating it because there's a
lot of vanity there I do think of 2017
some of the narcissistic kind of
vanities have gone away as all of us are
now kind of putting out content and
living some version of a personal brand
in comparison of 2008 when I real crush
in 2009 when it came out so you know yes
I'm a fan of it and I think there's a
lot of upside that comes with it but
like anything in life there's a yin yin
yang right so there's definitely some
baggage and some personal feelings
getting hurt he's got to have the
stomach for that feedback so I'm a fan I
think people should do it I think it's
good for business I do think that as
your business career evolved it means
that you have a base every time you
start something new if you
to go that route and so I'm passionate
about it I think it's good what did I
mean by fixing the plane while you're
flying it so I'm going we're fixing the
airplane while we fly it by the way by
the way by not by not taking a stop in
Providence Rhode Island to fix something
and then Kansas City Missouri
we've lapped the world 15 times well
everybody's still fixing their brakes
and [ __ ] in Wichita
the big thing there is that too many
people too many people aren't moving you
always have to be constantly moving it's
like right now just got done with these
hard roads I felt like I had in my mind
even though I'm not breathing super well
and just move it I'm just going to work
through it I'm not going to wait so many
people think that yep they're like stop
fix and go I think very much like it's
NASCAR right come in pit move I've got a
lot of problems at vaynermedia but I
don't stay off the offense on a lot of
the great things that are going on vein
or talent Maynard the small business
saying by the way small business area
you know the consulting stuff the video
production stuff the paid media stuff
Sugar's a lot of things to fix but too
many people dwell on what's wrong with
their organization and they spend all
their mind time their strategy on trying
to fix that that's like parking the
plane and fixing I'm like look I've got
to fix those things because if you don't
fix it the comedy brink but I'm going to
stay on the office I'm gonna keep flying
my plane and fixing it midstream and so
that's what I mean by that you don't the
dwell stop and address all your issues
and then when it's perfect you move
forward the huge mistake that slows you
down it's like so many people build
smaller businesses when the reasons that
those very big businesses is that of
course we've got to fix them because we
don't fix them to die but I'm always
scribbling down in my offense as well
[Music]